في اليابان اقتباس أظهر عدد كبير من مشاة البحرية الأمريكية المتمركزين في أوكيناوا إصابتهم بفيروس كورونا وفقًا للمسؤولين ولم تكشف القاعدة عن تفاصيل حول عدد المارينز المصابين مستشهدين بالأمن التشغيلي أه المسؤولون اليابانيون يعطون أرقامًا رغم أن أه كاوري وجورجي ينضمون إلينا الآن أه من طوكيو ، هذا يأتي ، هناك علاقة مضطربة منذ فترة طويلة بين الجيش الأمريكي وبعض الأشخاص في أوكيناوا ، أعتقد أن هذا لا يساعد مايكل تمامًا ، فهناك غضب متزايد وقلق عميق بعد تأكيد إجمالي 262 حالة بيننا العسكريين أفراد وعائلاتهم في ثلاث منشآت عسكرية أمريكية مختلفة الأسبوع الماضي وهذا يضع الحقائق بين جزيرة أوكيناوا اليابانية والمحطة العسكرية الأمريكية هناك على المحك مرة أخرى ، تم اختبار الحقائق مرارًا وتكرارًا عند وقوع حوادث أو جرائم وهذه المرة يتم اختبارها من قبل جائحة استغرق الأمر أيامًا حتى يؤكد الجيش الأمريكي
رقم يوم
السبت ويقولون تم إحصاء هذه الحالات
على مدى خمسة أيام الأسبوع الماضي
قال محافظ أوكيناوا إنه
صُدم لكون
أوكيناوا خالية من الفيروسات أو لا توجد
حالات جديدة من covet 19 في أوكيناوا منذ شهرين
أه بين الحين والآخر  يقول الحاكم إنه
شاهدنا عسكريين
يحتفلون ويريد مزيدًا من المعلومات حول
هذه الحالات الـ 19 لأنهم يريدون
القيام بشكل أفضل بتتبع الاتصال
أم الاستماع إلى تعليقات الحاكم
باستخدام كلمات مثل المؤسف
للغاية أه من الواضح أنه يمشي
بحبل مشدود للغاية بين  تحقيق التوازن بين
المصالح الأمنية
لليابان لأن واشنطن هي حجر
الأساس لسياسة الأمن اليابانية
وضمان صحة
ناخبيه أخبرني أنه
هذه المرة في أوكيناوا ، إنه
مشغول جدًا لأن الكثير منا نحن
الأفراد العسكريين يحبون نقل  العائلات
داخل وخارج الجزيرة ، الوقت الذي
تبدأ فيه المدارس
في الولايات المتحدة حوالي سبتمبر ، نظرًا
للانفجار  عدد الحالات التي
نراها في البر الرئيسي ،
يتزايد القلق بين سكان
أوكيناوا مايكل
خلال هذا الوباء ، شعرت هونغ كونغ
حقًا بأنها منطقة آمنة تقريبًا ، حيث
اتخذوا إجراءات في وقت مبكر جدًا لإغلاق
الحدود ،
واختبار كل شخص قادم إلى المدينة من أجل
covet 19 الحجر الصحي الإلزامي لمدة 14 يومًا
للمسافرين الوافدين
، وبالتالي فقد تمكنوا إلى حد كبير
من منع الفيروس من
الدخول من الخارج ولكن ما
لم يتمكنوا من التعامل معه
الآن
هو الحالات المنقولة محليًا في الواقع
سجل  مرتفع يوميًا
في عدد
حالات كوفيد 19 المنقولة محليًا هنا في هونغ كونغ
والأرقام ترتفع
كل يوم فهي لا تزال صغيرة نسبيًا
بالمقارنة ، أعني ضع في اعتبارك أن
هذه مدينة
مكتظة بالسكان 7 ملايين شخص يعيشون
هنا أقل من 1400  حالات الإصابة بالفيروس التاجي
حتى الآن
وسبع وفيات فقط ولكن إذا استمرت هذه
الأرقام في الارتفاع وإذا بدأ هذا الفيروس
في الانتشار في المجتمع إذا كان الناس
يتجولون ويتجولون  لا يعرفون أنهم
يمتلكون ذلك ،
يعرف خبراء الصحة أن هذه الأرقام يمكن أن
ترتفع
بشكل كبير وقد يكون ذلك سيئًا للغاية بالنسبة لهونغ كونغ
، فقد تمكنوا من تحديد
ثلاث مجموعات من العدوى في
المطاعم والحانات
في سيارات الأجرة وفي مراكز رعاية كبار السن ، لذلك
في كل من  تلك المناطق التي يتخذونها الآن
خطوات
لاختبار المزيد من الأشخاص ، فهم يفرضون إجراءات
أكثر تقييدًا للتباعد
الاجتماعي تبدأ في نهاية هذا الأسبوع ،
لذا في المطاعم لا يمكن إلا لثمانية أشخاص
الجلوس على طاولة
معًا وفي الحانات والنوادي الليلية يمكن لأربعة
أشخاص فقط الجلوس في
من المفترض أن يرتدي الأشخاص أقنعة في جميع
الأوقات إذا كانوا لا يأكلون أو يشربون ،
فهم يحاولون تتبع أه تعلمون
من كان يركب سيارات الأجرة مع السائقين
الذين ربما
أصيبوا بالعدوى على الرغم من أن هذا صعب هنا في
هونغ كونغ بسبب  يدفع الكثير من الأشخاص
نقدًا ولا يحصلون على إيصال ، وليس لديك أي
فكرة عمن يدخل ويخرج من سيارة الأجرة
، وفي المراكز العليا يحتاجون إلى اختبار
المزيد من الأشخاص الذين يحتاجون إلى اختبار المزيد
من العمال في تلك المراكز
حتى يتمكنوا من محاولة اكتشاف من لديه
هذا الفيروس وعزلهم
بأسرع ما يمكن
حتى لا يستمر المزيد من الناس في
التجول في هونغ كونغ ربما
ينشرون هذا الفيروس دون علم
ويجعل هذه الموجة الثالثة
أكبر بكثير من  حتى الموجتين السابقتين
سوف ريبلي سي إن هونغ كونغ
لك